family feasting football and doorbuster
deals I yes Black Friday the day after
Thanksgiving is the kickoff to the
holiday season and this unofficial
holiday is the biggest shopping day of
the year but where did this post turkey
Day event get its name from well it
started in Philadelphia during the
1960's when crowds of holiday shoppers
and rowdy fans flooded the city for the
annual army-navy football game the
horrendous traffic jams like overworked
police officers to start calling the day
Black Friday and it caught on
shopkeepers soon began using Black
Friday to describe two long lines of
rabbit stores Black Friday swept the
nation in the 1990s and started to
appear in retail ads and promotions
across the United States making
Thanksgiving weekend as much about
shopping as it is about food